Bud Light has just placed that VP of
marketing who pushed for the Dylan
Mulvaney beer can just placed her on
leave
this is Alyssa heinershide
not to be confused with sweet little
Elisa there's a huge variety among
leases around here
Alyssa heinershide
VP of marketing at Bud Light will for
now be replaced by Budweiser Global
Marketing VP Todd Allen
according to Anheuser-Busch inbev
telling ad age but she's just on leave
she hasn't been fired she's just she's
laying low for a little bit even this is
indecisive
she reminds me of an old political
principle which is sometimes a wrong
decision can be better than indecision
here since the Dylan Mulvaney
controversy Budweiser doubled down on
the sponsorship then pretended it didn't
know anything about the sponsorship then
made an advertisement about horses or
something then issued an apology letter
where there was no apology and it was
just the Budweiser CEO talking about how
much he supports the military or
something and then they but then they
can sort of continue to double down and
anyway now they're putting the VP on
leave but I don't know it's not it's
very very
indecisive and it's it's harming them
immensely I think they could have
survived it if they would just shut up
but they can't do it so they lose six
and a half billion in market cap and now
lots of borrowers won't even carry their
beer and now you've got Kid Rock just
shooting machine guns and boxes of Bud
Light because of how outrageous this
ideology is and now it's going to be
hard for them to recover
had they been decisive they either could
have doubled down and said yep we're now
the pro trans beer and plenty of
companies have done that and survived or
they could have said no this is insane
we support Frat Boys and construction
workers which is the actual
customer base about Bud Light but that
indecision has has given them the worst
of Both Worlds speaking of the public
turning public opinion
and speaking of Governor DeSantis great
news out of Florida 41 percent of
Floridians support Ron desantis's new
six-week abortion ban now they're going
to be some people who say six week
abortion man what about the baby zero to
six weeks I know I agree abortion is
wrong it's wrong to murder people
especially wrong to murder innocent
little babies and so yeah it's wrong and
we should just get rid of abortion
totally there are plenty of other
alternatives to abortion abortion solves
no problems it does not Rectify any
crimes it's just a crime in and of
itself totally agree
but you see DeSantis now just starting
to ratchet it up a little bit okay we
got this band now we got a 15-week band
now we're going to go to a six-week band
the great news here
is that the public seems to be going
along with him
at no point as Charlie cook points out
at National Review at no point in the
history of Gallup polling
did Gallup find 41 support for a ban on
abortion before
12 weeks in fact
support for abortion used to be much
much higher he says if we average out
the responses that Gallup obtains
between July 1996 and may 2022 we see
that 64 percent of Americans believe
that abortion should generally be legal
in the first three months of pregnancy
and now you've got 41 saying
it shouldn't be legal
after six weeks so that this is one of
these few issues on which the public has
become
much more pro-life well it's obviously
this is the one issue in which it's
become more pro-life this is one of the
few issues in which the public has moved
much much more into our corner and
you're seeing that play out in real time
and you're seeing the evidence of that
because conservative legislators and
governors are pushing these kinds of
bills reminds me of a line from Cardinal
Manning which is that there is a day to
come that will reverse The Confident
judgments of men we live in this ever
uh ever present or we think that we live
in an ever-present where nothing is ever
going to change the way things are right
now that's how they're always going to
be that's not true that's not how time
works that's not how history works
progressives think history works
in this totally straight fashion from
Bad olden days to good future days where
they're going to get rid of all the
conservatives and they're going to live
in a Utopia that's also not how history
works
sometimes The Confident judgments of men
will be reversed sometimes
the advancement of History sees people
moving more and more over to our views
these sane views of things it's a
reminder too of a line that's that's
alternately credited to Dean Inge and
Fulton Sheen which is that if you wed
yourself to the spirit of the age you
will find yourself a widow in the next
it's a lesson to all those squishy
Republicans don't
just buy into whatever you think is
popular or fashionable or inevitable
don't do it
buy into what is right this is what
DeSantis said on the trans issue he said
look
he said basically exactly what I just
said he said if you
are going to force this issue on us
you're telling me I've got to live
according to lies you're telling me that
I've got to participate in a lie I'm not
going to do that if you pursue the truth
it might make you unpopular at any
particular moment but you're going to be
in a much better position
in the long run right now go to
goodranchers.com use promo code Knowles
if you've not changed the way that you
buy meat yet you really need to I'm
going to give you three reasons that I
personally subscribe to good ranchers
number one good ranchers is giving you
free bacon for a year that's a pound and
a half of bacon in every box that's a
240 value second good ranchers offers a
price lock guarantee which is insane
when we've got record inflation means
that when you subscribe
your price does not change for the
entire length of your subscription when
the price of meat is expected to
increase by another four and a half
percent in the coming year this could be
a huge savings for you and your family
third golden ranchers meet is unlike any
other they're all natural Burgers USDA
prime steaks and better than organic
chicken will change your standard for
great meat I am very particular when it
comes to my food okay I am easily
Satisfied by the very best good ranchers
is Far and Away the best out there the
quality of the meat is just insane and I
eat good ranchers if not for the
outright majority of my meals total
three meals a day at least for the
plurality of them okay I just adore good
ranchers goodranchors.com use code
knowleskin wles for twenty dollars off
your box free bacon great meat a secure
price and a bonus 20 bucks off today
promo code Knowles at goodranchers.com
goodranchors.com American Meat delivered
so we got some big
big news baby
we got some we got a new candidate in
the race
for president that candidate
Larry Elder my announcement Tucker
is I'm announcing that I'm running for
the presidency of the United States on
your program and thank you so much for
giving me this honor and this platform
my website is elderforpresident.com
elderforpresident.com
and talking the reason I'm doing this is
because you know my father was a World
War II vet he served in in on the island
of Guam he was a Marine
first Black Marines are called Montford
Point Marines my older brother my late
older brother Kirk was in the Navy
during the Vietnam era and my little
brother Dennis actually served in
Vietnam in the Army I'm the only one who
didn't serve and I don't feel good about
that I feel I have a moral a religious
and a patriotic duty to give back to a
country that's been so good to my family
and to me and that is why I'm doing this
Tucker
well that's amazing congratulations
now uh Larry has been signaling that
he's interested in running for president
in in recent months so now he's coming
out he's doing it he is entering the
field his explanation is a fairly
standard conservative explanation which
is I want to serve you know if my my
country calls on me I'm going to do it
and Larry Elder's a very popular guy on
the right
so the reason that Larry's announcement
to me is so interesting
is because Larry is something of an
anomaly in the Republican field right
now there has always been something of
an anomaly it's La guy Sage from South
Central who's quite right wing uh
but he's something of an anomaly here in
that
the field is winnowing okay the field
which initially we were told no one's
going to run for president
Trump enters he's going to clear the
field
then Trump enters and
not everyone cleared the field some
people started announcing so then
conventional wisdom said
everybody's going to run for president
and that was briefly true everybody was
talking about running for president
everybody was exploring running for
president
and then
Ted Cruz said he wasn't going to run
and that at least he's signaled he's not
running I I don't know that he's
explicitly come out and said I am not
running for president but he he does not
appear to be doing the things that a
candidate would be doing I'm not even
playing Kawaii uh since we uh together
for three years
um it just doesn't seem like he's
running in 2024.
Mike Pompeo came out and explicitly said
I'm not running in 2024 even though he
had been strongly signaling that he
would Mike Pence it remains a little bit
uncertain
who else
a lot of the big guys seem to be sitting
this one out
because the field looks right now like a
two-man race you've got Vivek then
enters Nikki Haley enters Tim Scott
enters
maybe you get another candidate Chris
Christie is making some signals that
he'll run Chris sununu is making some
signals that he'll run ASA Hutchinson I
guess is declared that he's running
people haven't talked about that very
much Joe Exotic of course from Tiger
King but in terms of the relay
top polling top tier candidates
seems like it might be a more modest
field
than a lot of people say and Larry Elder
might have a spot on that debate stage
it's music Monday baby we got to get to
it the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it become a
member and use code Knowles at checkout
for two months free on all annual plans
dailywire.com Knowles code Knowles
[Music]
oh